did you guys catch the BBC's uh attempt
at interviewing Andrew Tate yeah I was a
massacre
wasn't it it was a [__] Massacre the
chick got got destroyed and it was so
obvious that what they wanted to do was
disingenuous and the fact that they cut
up the interview from 38 something
minutes down to 12 so that only showed
the bad parts and then they deleted it
it wasn't available
they Andrew you know tweeted about it
earlier in the day or yesterday I can't
remember what it was but he said
something along the lines of they had
sent them a list of questions in advance
unprovoked that they indicated that
their intention was to understand the
unjust incarceration what it's like in
the Romanian
um
you know jail system stuff like that and
they talked about none of that and I
thought that was quite interesting
especially when I watched the full 38
minute clip yeah which is which was
which is pretty disturbing I mean like
the mainstream meat is you know the
point where it's a national joke now and
I'm surprised anybody would even take it
even remotely seriously it's not
journalism anymore no exactly exactly
it's not journalism anymore they were
they were they sat down expecting some
Jim bro with muscles and money who's
flash instead they got someone with
muscles in the brain of Jordan Peterson
you know and they're they're not used to
that um you remember the Kathy Newman
and Gordon Peterson interview and it's
it's the same type of thing like I I
explained to my kids the other day watch
journalism you know they asked me about
journalism he says well a journalist is
someone who has a narrative and goes out
looking for their jigsaw puzzle pieces
to fit their narrative they don't want
to tell the truth anymore BBC had a
narrative about him and they just wanted
evidence to fulfill that narrative yeah
yeah it seems like they've completely
backed off the Jordan Peterson's evil
narrative and now it's like you know
Tate is a new uh bad guy because I think
he's an easier Target I mean he looks
meaner and better right
question is who's the next bad guy is it
you rich without it I'm not uh I mean I
haven't like there's no bad Canadians
yeah right I guess come on I mean like
an evil Canadian or someone who like has
two parking tickets or something I mean
I'm not a nice guy I mean I'm a kind man
but I'm not not a nice guy but I've
never really said anything
um that could be taken out of context
like I have editors that do clips for me
and and there's and there's clips that
go viral but it's not to the point where
it's like taking out a context where
it's like oh this guy's a misogynist or
he's dangerous or whatever I've never
seen that so it's mostly because I'm
pretty clean in my past and how I
communicate I like The Four Agreements
is an old book and some may or may not
you know recognize it but one of the
agreements is being impeccable with your
word
um I try to be as clear as clear and as
concise as possible and that doesn't
generate massive views and it's not as
controversial but I think it's a better
place to be
you're also walking on the safe side
because you're not using controversy to
gain views so you're not going for the
red meat you're not going for the
controversial you're more close to I
don't know
Rich what's what's the name of that book
that you said The Four Agreements The
Four Agreements yeah uh John Miguel you
uh Ruiz I believe is the author okay
because I saw a great Buffett quote the
other day and it was must be from Warren
Buffett because then it was on the
internet in meme format so it must be
him
um it was you can't make good deals with
bad people yeah you can and there's
there there was a New York Times article
a few years ago it went viral uh the
Management Consultant wrote about the no
[__] rule that it doesn't matter how
good someone is in your company your
corporation what kind of minor if
they're an a-hole they're going to be
toxic to the whole thing and as you said
if your ward is your bond well then you
if someone is decent you shouldn't have
to tie them down with you know 10 page
legal documents yeah it's a whole you
know um you lay with dogs you're gonna
get fleas I mean that's why I got out of
the manual swamp because there's too
many dogs in that space and I've uh it
just continues to reaffirm the decision
was good I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out